we're seeing questions come on YouTube
ask Laura and I anything and we have
team members who are looking at them and
and we're going to surface them and
actually I'll start with a question from
YouTube and that did help thanks Laura
so this is from YouTube Nikhil NGO
vendor asks asked us both but I'm more
curious about your answer I'm happy to
give a little bit as well what was your
inspiration to help others in terms of
Education and I guess you know why focus
on education of all the things in the
world well again this was not terribly
premeditated when we started bedtime
after we were just kind of doing this
for fun with our kids but when we shared
the math problems what happened first is
basically there are a lot of hyper
competitive parents my town and they
wanted to know what we were doing with
our kids so I started sharing the math
promised to people and I was stunned at
how these college-educated parents many
of them Ivy League were so nervous that
I hadn't put the answers to the
questions and they'd say to me I know
five plus two is seven but I feel better
if you put the answer to the bottom
because initially I didn't put the
answers and you know it just really was
a wake-up call about what math anxiety
is out there you know we have a country
of people who are nervous about
calculating the tip and this includes
high school grads college grads they're
nervous about the tip and that is a
fourth and fifth grade math skill as you
well know it's not that hard and I truly
believe everybody can do it and we have
to get there because I think when you
talk about the fall of an empire I mean
we're doing a lot of things wrong in
this country but having people afraid of
4th grade math is not helping so it just
really lit a fire under me to get out
there and see if I could move the needle
on this now that makes me think about
two things one is there is just this so
many people's brains just something
happened to them trauma something where
math they just shut down I mean your
example of you know Ivy League grads
wanting the comfort of an answer to a
you know a first grade or kindergarten
type type problem and and just for all
any of you who think the tip calculation
is just valuable for calculating tips
which it is you know this is actually an
interview question we used to use at
Khan Academy for a lot of entry-level
jobs where we just said
we just gave a little bit of a word
problem you and five friends go to a
restaurant you all order this this you
want to pay the right amount of tip
someone pays this mom how much did you
pay or how much change should there be
and you'd be surprised how how many
people with college degrees had trouble
answering those questions so you might
see it as an interview question and I'll
just have to Laura you know if you think
about education it's just a single
leverage point that I think builds on
everything else you know human capital
is the ultimate capital and if we can
let that grow it'll go to positive uses
if you don't not only will it after fee
but it could go in negative direction so
that's my two cents
so from YouTube
Jeana Guzman asked question for Laura
according to different home realities
what is the most suitable schedule for
distance learning so yeah what advice
would you have I mean I just think that
we have all been thrown into a situation
we were not anticipating and I feel
particularly for kids in grades K
through to where it is very hard for
them first to focus for very long on a
computer secondly even to use the
computer to touch the mouse to click on
the wrong window by accident their
teacher disappears we find when we
practice our games with our staffs and
kindergarteners it's very different the
parents end up being very involved and
that is really a strain on a family
where the parents are working it's also
a strain I know there's a lot of talk
about clearly the inequities where kids
don't have a device at home or Wi-Fi you
have to add in then all the people where
there is a device in the home but
everybody needs it there multiple kids
or there's a parent working from home so
I think as far as what works for
schedule I think you have every scenario
out there as a start though it seems to
me that kids hit the ground running in
the morning it is much harder to engage
after lunch during food coma and I think
also that it's really emotionally
healthy for kids to see their guide
their teacher if possible in the morning
at the start of the day even if it's
brief and then from there get their
structure for the day and move from
there
I don't know if that fully answers the
question but I also think we don't even
really know all the answers because
they're just so many scenarios out there
and it's really challenging yeah I think
that consists what we're seeing I mean
what we're telling very consistent we're
saying hey it just gets started even if
you're able to do twenty minutes thirty
minutes a day of math reading maybe
writing that's a start and students
won't atrophy and and that I think
lowers the stress level and then you can
layer on more we've you know we've
published schedules and things like that
as well but I think you're exactly right
it depends on your circumstance and this
is a time where people definitely should
not put more stress on themselves if
they can avoid it but no one should beat
up on themselves and I was just gonna
add one more point that's kind of
related which is I think the fact that
we're not kids are not with their
teachers is making us more aware of how
powerful that is tools like Khan Academy
and all the resources out there that
enable kids to personalize their work
are incredibly important but we still
need to pair a human with it like
teachers should never worry that any of
this is going to make us not have
teachers in the future I think teachers
are incredibly important and a piece of
research I was so struck by is work out
of the University of Washington I labs
where they do MRIs of babies they've put
they created a helmet that you put on
the baby's head and they use math to do
motion correction and you can watch the
baby's brain while things happen and it
turns out if you touch a baby's hand or
the baby's mom's hand while the mom is
sitting there certain parts of the brain
light up if you show the baby a video of
her mom with her hand being touched
those parts don't light up we really do
react differently and in a much more
powerful way when were with people
physically and so I mean I'm looking
forward to the end of this and everybody
getting back to school because I think
that that's such an important part of
education I'm also hoping then that we
find a way to pair that with the
liberation I was talking about earlier
of having kids really see what they need
to be working on and what they need to
master that's fascinating I think it's a
suit it's super worth triply underlining
I think all of us we always knew the
power of teachers and the work they did
but I think this is all driven our
empathy much much higher for the amazing
work they
do with our children and sometimes how
how how hard it can be and I actually
want to make sure I understand that that
was fascinating you said obviously you
would expect if the child's own hand
gets touched that would light up parts
of their brain but you're saying if
their parent is in their presence or
their mothers in their presence and
someone touch the mother's hand that
would it's mind-blowing because it shows
that infants even a few hours after
birth
have empathy I mean they don't know what
a hand is they don't know that that's
their hand and the mom like they don't
know that that hand matches their hand
that it's the corresponding point and
yet when you touch the mom's hand it
lights up I think it's just incredible
research and they're continuing to do
more on this out of AI labs at
University of Washington but I think it
just has so many implications for how
you want a blended learning package
where you have the content where a kid
can really work on their own but you
definitely want a human in the picture
too and we want the best of worlds
absolutely and we have a couple of
questions which i think is interesting
especially considering your background
laura from we have a question from
Nikhil actually again from YouTube a
salad Laura what made you interested in
mathematics how do you make chill and
then for Aditya is asking how do you
make children interest in math and I'd
love to connect that to your background
you are if I remember an astrophysicist
by training I am so-and-so so what got
you interested in math so you know I
look back at this and I think the thing
is that when I was a kid I had a mom and
a dad who loved math and just worked it
into the day math didn't feel like a
separate subject like I never got
flashcards or worksheets at home my
parents both had hobbies and really
would do those with me so my mom is an
amazing cook and she had me very early
on measuring with teaspoons and
tablespoons and fractions and you just
get really fluent in fractions very you
know a lot earlier than you do in school
and then my dad does a lot of carpentry
and he
using unsafe power tools at a very young
age and you know what if you don't want
to take off your thumb you better know
what a sixteenth of an inch is and
you're really you know using fractions
there too as well as tying it with very
physical tangible objects and I think
that's part of it too is for me math was
always tangible I'm a very visual and
kinetic learner as opposed to auditory
and that really lit has led us to do
what we do at that time as we're now we
have these hands-on games and I see how
kids who don't necessarily learn from
hearing a lecture move things around on
the table and see it in a completely
different way and that's what fun factor
is so we're now every Monday and
Wednesday running a live a live webinar
where teachers can get on and find out
how to do these games with their
students but families can get on to I
mean it's just open for anybody who'd
like to see but it's really to bring the
hands-on object back in to pair with the
other forms of learning because kids
have different styles of learning that's
fascinating and it sounds like a fun
householder growing I agree I was
actually doing some baking with my kids
recently and you know as soon as you go
off the recipe it's like we're gonna
make a two-thirds portion of this the
math fraction math was very very real
and like we like to do half the sugar
and it definitely starts hitting you and
I'd look up a little bit more on your
background I mean what got you into
astrophysics in particular I'm guessing
from that period where you were doing
fractions with your mom and dad - going
to become going into astrophysics
there's a lot more math you've gotten
excited and some things that explain
that well what got you interested I love
as well but yeah well actually I would
say for quite a while through elementary
and middle school I really thought of
myself as a math kid I loved math I
liked playing with numbers on this side
looking at patterns and perfect squares
I mean I was really into numbers in a
very abstract way but then I took
physics junior year and just fell in
love with it cuz that my teacher dr.
stone back was hysterical and also just
really willing to off road willing to
take our
questions and just throw out the lesson
plan and experiment with whatever we
were asking about and I just love the
class and then that summer I got to go
to Governor's School which is a program
that's in many states and I went for the
sciences and took an astronomy class and
was just blown away by it and and fell
in love with it and I'd always loved the
night sky and been curious but it kind
of all came together when I learned more
about how it all works so that was um
and I should note that actually a P so
what's interesting is when I was a
junior that was the year the Challenger
blew up and that was a very emotional
thing to see happen but it really drove
home for me what an amazing thing these
people were going to go try to do I've
always just been fascinated by that and
for a while I wanted to be an astronaut
but I've lazy eye which is not
correctable so I can't be a pilot and at
the time very few people were mission
specialists so to go on and get the PhD
and hope to be an astronaut it just
seemed like not a terribly likely path
so sadly I did not pursue it but I am so
excited that we are hopefully gonna have
recreational space travel for all of us
in the next few years that's what I'm
moving forward
ya know space is definitely one of the
topics that I'm fascinated and and my
astronaut dreams I squash them to myself
once I realized how to foster feel but I
am okay if I do not have the right stuff
so to speak but I wanna but I'm on
discover I want to know what we discover
as we as we learn more about the
universe and travel to to other places
and I'll just throw out you know my own
quick response for that math you know
when you really just peel the envelope
of understanding reality math is the
purest way of understanding reality
everything else has a layer of our
senses and our mental models that we
construct but math is so pure and you
know I've said this other times if we
ever have to communicate with another
alien life-form you know staying on the
space theme the way that we could
actually probably communicate that each
of us are intelligent it's probably
through math communicate well beyond
that but we can at least say look know
we're thinking look there's some prime
numbers are yeah and I should note also
just one point from that was the
I hit a point where math connected with
something that I fell in love with and I
think when we talk about what helps kids
love math seeing the real-life
application seeing exciting jobs they
use math you know kids are so into video
games all that programming behind the
scenes there's a ton of math in there
and you know just connecting the dots
like that for kids I think is really
important I was lucky to have that one
interesting question you know I saw this
with my cousin Nadia when I went you
know this is kind of the famous how Khan
Academy started she was 12 years old
she's trouble in math and I remember
even when I started tutoring her you
know this was back in 2004
you know she had already convinced
herself I'm not good at math maths not
my thing
I suspect that some of it has to do with
gender stereotypes maybe messages she
got from the broader world clearly that
did not happen to you why do you think
that does happen and how if you're a
parent and you and I do believe
especially in that middle school age
that's when people start to perceive
themselves I'm a math person or I'm this
type of person or I'm not that type of
person what what advice do you have for
parents to kind of to deprogram that
that's social programming yeah there is
so much it is such a systemic problem
coming from all angles and especially
with girls I think that you know I think
it's simpler than we sometimes make it
it's really important to taste victory
and to have another person validate that
for you and say you know you are really
good it's funny because I've never had
math anxiety and always loved math but
my equivalent I would say was gym
anxiety when I was a kid because I had
skipped a grade so I was young and I was
also small for my age and I did ballet I
was very dainty I was not remotely
athletic and in gym when they'd go to
pick teams over and over I was always
picked last then I would do badly
because of course I wasn't confident
that would validate for everybody yep
you want to pick her last and this went
on for years and it was terribly
humiliating this was painful and then in
ninth grade we did Presidential Fitness
and one of the events is the high jump
and thanks to my springiness from ballet
I beat the whole grade in the high jump
never having done it
and the gym teacher who told that
thought I was a loser said to me oh my
gosh when you two on the track and field
team get out there that was just
life-changing I went and I ended up
being a hurdler I never would have done
that if I hadn't had a moment where I
actually succeeded it's something and to
have the adults say no you're not
imagining that you really did it so I've
thought a lot about how do we bring this
to math because I think math anxiety is
so similar you know Seon by Locke who's
done amazing Studies on the neuroscience
behind all this has shown that when if
you're afraid of math when you do math
problems that fear actually blocks your
working memory and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy so you know
it's really important to feel confident
with math but this also gets back to
giving kids the right challenge to be
working on so they do master it and
that's why you don't want the Swiss
cheese holes in the learning right you
want to figure out what do kids need to
fill in have them work at it and it
might mean going back to kindergarten
and starting with the really basic stuff
this is what we do with our math problem
every little fun story about ninjas or
flamingos kicks off with a pre-k
question and I think having kids go to
the beginning do that and it's like yeah
you got that see okay let's do the
little kid question you know how to
count to five see you've got this and
working on up kids need to taste victory
and I think that really it is as simple
as that that that turns it around I love
that because it you know when when
you're going through your stories of
your life and really reflect a little
bit on my stories and I think you're
right you know early on I had probably a
little bit of communication anxiety I
was actually in speech therapy when I
was very young and I didn't and I was
very shy and actually I'm still more
introverted than most people suspect and
I'm good acting I like I like being with
people I like Congress actually I'll
ever they liked conversations like this
I don't like cocktail parties where you
know you have to make small talk and
then move on to the next and you kind of
have to move into someone else that's
not that I'd rather just hide in the
bathroom but the but but what you're
right I mean those times that I got my
aperture opened about
times about myself maybe I can
communicate maybe I could be a good
writer was when I did something and
someone gave that positive feedback and
I read or was authentic it wasn't just
they're just trying to make me feel good
but that did feed on itself it does it
becomes true it really does something
there and and so I have these good
conversations time goes by super fast I
think we have time for a few more
questions
so from YouTube si Sanchez a question
for Miss / Dec what is what is it like
knowing something from a kid's bedroom
became so big you know so they're
talking about bedtime math and I guess
I'll add to that question what advice do
you have for folks you know both your
narrative and my narrative Khan Academy
and bedtime math these all started from
family projects very organic but
something happened in your mind and my
mind's like maybe the more people could
benefit from this so what advice would
you have for other folks to kind of
solve big problems like that yeah so as
far as how it feels you know it it
really took off very fast I started
sharing math problems with families in
our town and the list grew really fast
people started telling other people
about it but I I got hit by lightning
the New York Times reviewed my blog
about a month after I started it that
just isn't fair way and so that brought
in thousands of people and it then grew
very fast on the other hand I am a math
person I'm always looking at the zeros
on the ends of the numbers and I know
that there are 25 million kids in our
country in that time maths target market
and we don't have anywhere near we do
not have enough of those zeros so it's
big and yet it's small it's really hard
to move the needle I guess we've had
over quarter million downloads of our
app but that's one percent of the market
so I wake that gets me out of bed every
morning thinking about how to get it to
more people and as far as like what
clicked and and you know again it was
actually external people because it was
other people saying hey what are you
doing I mean it's not too different from
the gym teacher saying hey wait a minute
look what you're doing go do that bigger
you know I think that the more we
encourage each other and unfortunately
we've you know we don't always have
opportunity
to do this or don't do it as much as we
should but when we encourage others I
think we don't even realize the massive
impact we might be having at that moment
without realizing it because it can
actually steer people's trajectory
completely and one interesting you used
made a small comment like you know I got
struck by lightning implying that you
know you got lucky New York Times but I
think there's something there which is
in order to get struck by that lightning
you have to build a bit of a lightning
rod and obviously literally I don't want
anyone to build lightning rods to get
struck by lightning but figuratively
yeah by putting that out there you
wouldn't you wouldn't want to invent it
incidentally by Benjamin Franklin he
doesn't get his enough credit I think as
a scientist but anyway the the but you
don't you you don't a lot of things you
can't put in a strategic plan that the
New York Times will write about us on
this date and same thing similar things
happen in Khan Academy but the fact that
you took it as a family project
you you you allowed that feedback you
started scaling it up and then it was
there to be discovered I think is a
interesting layer there yeah it's at
that point cuz I agree with you you have
to just take your thing and get out
there with it and see what happens and
this reminds me of another point which
is that you are not looking for
perfection when you do that waiting for
your thing to be perfect you will never
get it out there there's a great book
called Lean Startup it's one of my
favorite books and they talk about
Minimum Viable Product you take you take
the basic idea don't put a whole lot of
effort to it just come up with what it
is put it out there and let the market
say to you you know we love that but
could you make it purple or could you
make it twice the size or could you
deliver it faster or whatever it is and
all our growth at bedtime app a lot of
it has been from people giving us that
feedback and of course for you I know
you were doing your videos for your
cousin and I'm sure you were just kind
of whipping those together for and then
look at what has happened I mean it's
the exact same thing if you had waited
for them to be perfect and frankly they
were close to perfect already but if you
waited for them to be perfect it might
have never happened and I think a lot of
times people feel a little bit of
paralysis and it's it's better to just
take the risk and take the thing 80
percent
percent done and just get out there yet
I'll add to that I think there might be
an element that sometimes the what you
think is perfect is less perfect than
the thing that's more authentic and a
little raw I mean you know that's why I
got out of my head when you said you
know the Khan Academy videos they still
have a little bit of that you know I
still make it here at this desk right
here with this microphone and there's
still these hand-drawn things we've
improved it a reasonable bit but I think
if someone had given me you know a large
grant from the government or for us
working for a large publisher 15 years
ago and said make math videos I would
have fallen into the trap that a lot of
people have was making these fairly well
produced things but they read like you
know welcome to the next step in
quadrant quadratics it feels like a GPS
device and people don't connect with it
and there's an authenticity around
around sometimes the the 80% solution so
100% agree with you so maybe finish on
one a question because you just talked
about this paralysis of sometimes when
people want to do anything they're they
want the perfect becomes the enemy of
the good
knee a shoe on YouTube asks what's the
trick for not getting afraid of the word
math I mean how to overcome the problem
especially when preparing for some
entrance exam like for I guess in her
situation the GMAT what what advice I
mean you're someone who's never had math
anxiety do you empathize with that and
and what advice do you have and I'm
happy to give my two cents as well you
know I I do emphasize because I mean
math is a four-letter word unfortunately
for a lot of people and I've seen this
and I've had fans email in and just talk
about this with their kids so I think
there are a couple things one is
expanding what we think math is for
instance there's a lot of spatial stuff
and math and spatial relations rotation
of objects that's all math too and a lot
of people that's a different part of the
brain and a lot of people are good at
that and don't ever really get to show
it off in fact you can see behind me of
these little tiles this is one of our
games that we're doing on our webinars
these fun factor games where kids make
these squares and have to match them to
patterns and sometimes you find that
kids who are not particularly good at
math in school are just rock stars at
this and saying you know what that's
math you're good at that again
you have to taste victory and then I
think also as far as how do we make math
not a bad word we are all in this
together I hear people say you know I'm
just not good at math I hate math a
study showed that something like 72
percent of moms think they're not
qualified to help their kids with their
math homework that is a thing that's a
deep conversation we have to have as a
country to kind of get over that because
really I really think anyone can do math
and what you want is for the parent to
learn the math with the child the parent
the Guardian whoever it is and get
comfortable and even if adults are not
comfortable something we shouldn't say
it in front of the kids like just keep
it to yourself because kids don't start
off not liking math they love it
they come to our Crazy Eights
after-school Club and they have a great
time and they actually don't even
believe it's the same thing they're
doing at school
it is math they don't they don't start
off not liking it we're causing that so
we we can solve the problem it's up to
us yeah home your pretend agree cuz math
at the end at the end of the day it's
puzzles it's logic and all of us are
drawn to games puzzles logic and and
that's in the math even in the academic
math but sometimes that gets lost and so
my only two cents to add to what Laura
add it is you know whether math is your
phobia public speaking is your phobia
writing is Truffaut be or whatever it is
gym class is your phobia I think it's
the paralysis of sometimes wanting the
perfect to be it's the enemy it's good
sometimes it's you feel like the world
will then you know my son was getting
very nervous for a piano recital and
he's like and I'm like Imran it's not
like it's gonna be the end of the world
and his response is what if it is like
you know the earth parts and a lot of
erupts
Pachelbel's Canon I mean it was a fun
moment but we just have to remember the
war the earth is not gonna end you just
give your best attempt and at the end of
the day you are you are not your math
scores or or whatever else and that will
actually liberate you to do better and
to Laura's point for all these people
with math things I just get started just
do you know the quote frozen to do the
next right thing and for all those
parents out there if you put in even 10
15 minutes on Khan Academy you can learn
it for your kids and model it so Laura
you know one last question
I want to be conscientious of your of
your time you know huh what messages you
have for everyone out there who's
socially distanced families are trying
to keep the learning going well how can
they make we know what are the silver
linings here what are some some ideas
that you're able to experience in your
own family there may be other people can
commute to cope with what's going on
well I do think that one silver lining
is that families are kind of now
learning together in a way that they
don't when the kids are off at school
and everybody else is home or at work so
I think loosening up what we think
learning is that what we think education
is there's some funny videos videos out
there saying you know household chores
can be math or cooking could be math but
it's actually I mean maybe it's not the
chores but there are a lot of things
that just go on in your house that
involve numbers there are a lot of fun
things that involve reading and I think
loosening up what we think learning is I
think we get in a track where we see
what goes on in school we say oh that's
what learning is and then you leave
school and come home
and other stuff happens we are learning
all the time and we're just now more
aware that you can do a lot of learning
at home because put in your home all day
you suddenly have all this time to
explore it is really hard being home
it's really hard not being able to get
supplies food everything is harder right
now and to varying degrees for people
but I think just knowing that this is
it's temporary and let's make the most
of it and really get to bond over other
kinds of learning and I mean it really
is the time to pull out the board games
the decks of cards the dice poker chips
everything because all of that is
learning to and let's take advantage of
the fun time and do that that's great
advice Laura thanks so much for joining
and answering our questions oh and thank
you so much for having me and for doing
this show because I know you at Khan
Academy have had an explosion of traffic
this last month and have your hands full
so it's it's awesome you're doing the
show and done oh no this has been a
blast for us too thank you thank you
well well everyone another you know
always fun to talk to Laura
thanks for joining this I think we got
some good advice today and you know stay
safe stay healthy as we go through these
unusual times but there are some silver
lining some ways to keep learning some
ways to get even more connected with
family and discover things about the
universe that you might not have had the
time or the space to do in the past and
we hope to help you or help you help
others as you're a parent or teacher in
any way we can so we look forward to
what is today Thursday we look forward
to seeing you tomorrow have a good night
or an evening afternoon I don't know
[Laughter]
you